[Applause]
and finally new rules since this is our
last show of the season in our
Thanksgiving show I'd like to start
tonight by giving thanks this year to
Donald Trump and all the loons Karen's
Kool-Aid drinkers d-list celebrities and
unqualified weirdos he put up for office
who scared some sense into America on
Election Day
[Applause]
and thus made this holiday season so
much brighter for me and millions of
other Americans thank you Republican
douchebags class of 22.
foreign
o and Tudor Dixon and Carrie Lake and
Blake Masters and all the other election
deniers who ran for Secretary of State
and governor and swing States and lost
which was almost all of them and
Republicans like Brad rafsenberger who
defied Trump and won yes in 2022 against
everybody's predictions except Michael
Moore foreign
The deniers Lost and the defiers won and
America showed the world that the
reports of our death were slightly
exaggerated
we went from God damn America to God
damn America
maybe we're not quite as crazy as we
look Republicans showed they could dump
their baggage in Independence showed
they could actually be independent
usually they're just closet Republicans
but this year they did what they never
do in midterms they came out in droves
for the party in power and told the
party that ran on a platform of [ __ ]
elections go [ __ ] yourselves
sometimes this country surprises you
with its ability to revert back to sane
we saw it when we elected the first
black president we saw it with the
acceptance of gay marriage and at the
end of disco
we saw it when we ended prohibition and
segregation and stopped allowing doctors
to smoke during surgery
one day we may even stop making comic
book movies
sure we're a country that chose to
deliberately eat Tide Pods but how about
some credit for when we eventually
stopped
but this year this year was something
special our better Angels haven't put up
a win like that in a long time turns out
we're not guilty by reason of insanity
and right now I feel like we're having a
not as crazy as we thought moment let's
keep it going
to keep it going
let's
[Music]
let's rally the normies which we now
realize are still most of us and Bully
the bullies on the extreme ends who are
such a tiny part of us and yet thanks to
social media and partisan politics are
able to hog the microphone and make
everything suck
friend Jonathan here noted on 60 Minutes
that the extremists are only about seven
to eight percent on both sides and yet
they get 90 percent of the media
attention 92 percent of all Tweets in
this country come from 10 of the users
why are we letting 15 of the population
make us all miserable it's like we're
letting the crying baby fly the plane
[Applause]
yeah
all the normal Republicans who stepped
up last week great beginning let's keep
it going don't stay silent about
Insanity just because it's coming from
your team call out this conspiracy stuff
marginalize the people who believe in
crisis actors and lizard people
and who think Democrats eat babies or
run pedophile Rings Jewish space lasers
I don't even know what a Jewish space
laser is foreign
[Applause]
Irving doesn't believe in it
we all need to call out the people of
bad faith on both sides who pretend
things they know are not true like voter
fraud it's been studied a million times
it doesn't exist there just aren't
hordes of people showing up in
gray-haired wigs pretending to be dead
people
and risking prison to vote for Patrick
Leahy
[Applause]
voting twice it's hard enough to vote
once
okay you admit that and liberals will
admit that getting a picture ID is not a
Herculean burden that minorities can't
manage like everybody else and which
most don't even object to
we need more Grand Bargains like that
everyone's always talking about how
they're tired of the extremists now they
long for compromise then do it make
deals stop flirting with
authoritarianism and we'll stop flirting
with Communism
foreign
stop saying Democrats eat babies
[Laughter]
and we'll stop saying men can have them
[Applause]
stop denying the ice caps are melting
and we'll stop asking him to disband ice
stop saying there's a war on Christmas
and we'll admit Kwanza is completely
made up
foreign
boys and we'll see what we can do about
Kanye all right
all right let's all agree to form a less
psycho Union